this video is brought to you by
manscape.com
so uh
i've had an interesting week a few days
ago i read this page of naruto and
without posting my thoughts on it i
shared the image on twitter
this was a mistake never in all of my
life had i seen such vitriol venom and
pure hatred ooze out from a fan base
before remember now i don't know
anything about naruto and unbeknownst to
me i had just stumbled into one of the
most hated arguments i've yet come
across on the internet that didn't have
to do with politics people were
attacking each other heck people were
attacking me i didn't even say anything
yet and my proximity to the argument was
enough to entice some folks into
ordering the deletion of my account if
my opinion on a cartoon girl they liked
or disliked didn't match theirs it's not
a cartoon it's anime
i am ready for war
this is gonna be a great
[Music]
video following the events of the pain
assault kanoa is uniquely weakened with
the likes of even lady tsunade the fifth
hokage in a comatose state resulting in
danzo the prick who brainwashed sai and
has been slithering around in the
background for a while now becoming the
sixth okay in her absence i can smell
conflict brewing already in order to
decide what to do about the akatsuki
members on the loose a summon of all
five kage is held and prior to leaving
for this gathering danzo's first rule is
to effectively authorize the killing of
sasuke overturning tsunade's rule
entirely this was a great start to the
story i found it sets up the building
blocks to be knocked down so to speak
following the pain assault arc while we
still have this nebulous overarching
goal of regrouping with sasuke in order
to convince him to come back to the
village without a concrete plan of how
best to do that it remains a less
immediate concern in the forefront of
what i would assume is a great many
readers despite it being the main
motivation for naruto himself with that
said however the combination of this
overarching motivation and the addition
of a new hokage in danzo creates a
unique pressure to be applied to this
desire from naruto for sasuke not to
mention conflict with the akatsuki and
five great nations finally all of these
chess pieces are starting to come
together in a meaningful way and right
now i can really feel a progression
towards a big finish in this arc
naruto needs to watch what he does in
his presence he doesn't want to give
danzo a reason to lock him away as a
jinchuriki thankfully it's demonstrated
that not only will naruto not be acting
heatily or emotionally in response to
all of this but in fact quite the
opposite when faced with some cloud
ninjas looking for information on sasuke
in an aggressive manner sakura is
reduced to tears with the news that they
lay before her and instead of pushing
back against these unwarranted words of
antagonism that speak ill not only of
his friend sasuke but causes sakura
distress naruto doesn't act how he might
have acted in the past he uses the fact
he's a jinchuriki as a means of bridging
the gap between their village and his he
says that they shouldn't be focusing on
capturing sasuke and seeking revenge but
instead focusing on rescuing their
sensei first it's another instance that
demonstrates how much naruto has grown
as a person and also how his experiences
with those that seek revenge have
transformed him into someone that does
not seek that out knowing where it can
lead one down naruto is like the
ultimate hero's journey in this respect
at every turn he tries to defuse any and
all attention while avoiding glorifying
his own goals and circumstances he
willingly accepts a beating from the
cloud ninja to help them stop the cycle
of violence vengeance will ultimately
bring them down in seeking out sasuke
and when he shares the important
information about his meeting with the
fourth hogage in his mind he chooses not
to share that he was his father and i
think that's really telling of where
naruto is right now mentally when one
gloats one does so because they feel
insecure about another person's
perception of them and wants to elevate
their standing artificially in their
peers eyes in the beginning naruto was a
real blowhard and that was a reaction to
how others belittled and neglected him
however nowadays he's adored by the
people he has no need to gloat if
anything he's incredibly humble about
this meeting instead telling kakashi
what he felt was the most important part
of it to him that his father believed in
him
but let's get to some plot stuff okay
following this naruto goes to the kage
summit escorted by kakashi and yamato
with the mission being that of peace
belief and love in and of itself seems
to be a strong theme in this story and
primarily this arc too naruto values
what belief can do for someone and so
won't turn his back on his friend sasuke
he will always believe that he can be
saved kakashi believes in naruto then as
a result and so follows him on what ends
up being a complete waste of time
mission to request peace at the summit
and even with sai this is a character
that sits on the fence between danzo and
naruto one who if left to his own
devices would most likely have chosen
naruto due to his belief insight compare
that to danza who trusts virtually no
one and even goes as far as to curse
seal sye's tongue from speaking against
his interests it's screwed up but this
all has a greater purpose the main
thematic takeaway i gleaned from this
arc was that of two diametrically
opposed ideologies setting themselves up
for an inevitable collision down the
road and we see all of this information
as the world summit heals nothing but
distrust and lack of belief in the
current structure as danzo sought to
manipulate the little good will that
existed through the land of iron
suggestion that he be the five nation
army leader at the beginning at least
the parts of the ark that deal with the
political unrest that's brewing while
being a little wordy at times felt
appropriate for the setting and
interesting throughout for me not
overstaying their respective welcomes
either might you as tensions climb in
the summit beating and dishonesty is
rooted out the physical reason for their
mistrust in the first place makes itself
known to everyone and it doesn't stop
there either
there's a story that's shared with us of
two sons that belong to this akatsuki
obito the older song believed that peace
could only be achieved through power
while the younger believed it could be
achieved through love a clear thematic
parallel with the characters of sasuke
and naruto respectively with even more
again sasuke being the embodiment of
this power-hungry ideology speaks to his
prior engagements and the same to be
true for naruto sasuke's older brother
itachi subscribed closer to love than
sasuke did who showed him little mercy
leading to his death embracing hatred
embracing revenge whereas naruto
particularly as he gained better control
over himself which speaks to this being
the more difficult path has found
success in treating people with mercy
and love with one of those very people
naruto helped gara even going as far as
to try and convince sasuke to return to
kanoa in naruto's stead in other words
thanks to naruto gara can now see how
lost sasuke is how obsessed with
aggression hatred and power he seems
which brings him to tears he's been
there before it's a great moment and
these themes of love versus hatred trust
versus aggression belief versus distrust
and responsibility are what makes this
arc as philosophically interesting as it
otherwise ends up being ignoring the
obvious being naruto's position on the
side of trust that doesn't entirely mean
that that side is the obvious correct
choice either a significant portion of
the story deals with naruto's friend
group primarily sakura and the guilt
they and she feels for putting too much
of their trust and belief in naruto
placing him under tremendous pressure
with the question becoming should they
deal with this themselves are they being
selfish by expecting naruto to work a
miracle here and it's easy to see why
they come to this decision they do the
choices kishimoto made to inject nuance
into the story like this makes what
could have become an otherwise far too
simple and straightforward story into an
exciting one and that's exactly what you
need to do when writing an arc that
hinges so much on dialogue and
introspection like this there is a
decent amount of fighting in this arc
once the jig is up and sasuke's crew
decides to make their presence felt at
the summit watching a sasuke contends
with each kage that stood in his way was
a real page turner forcing him to break
out moves some of which i expect in
others i didn't things most definitely
don't go 100 according to plan and in
these skirmishes sasuke receives some
big hits not to mention his chakra gets
depleted the main significant takeaway
from this i took was that of sasuke's
reliance on his friends or the cell team
he assembled should i say with
practically every encounter he engages
with here had it not been for his team
having his back he would surely have
lost following this activity matara
shows up and saved sasuke from certain
defeat taking this as his opportunity to
announce the fourth shinobi war with his
goal being that of the natural extreme
of mistrust and yearning for power he
wishes to control and to absorb the
power of the nine-tailed beasts in order
to control the world stripping the
populace of their autonomy thus securing
world peace as a result of that control
i guess now we have an endgame and while
the five nations agree to join forces
against this foe given the mistrust that
they have for one another i can't see
that working out so what happens next
[Music]
now i know cousin it from the addams
family israel hashtag yas queen squad
goals but it's time to get trimmed up
with manscape's new lawnmower 4.0
electric trimmer you get this wonderful
waterproof shaver and more when you
purchase their new performance package
4.0 along with it comes the crop
preserver ball deodorant and the crop
reviver ball toning spray to keep you
smelling fresh all damn day but did you
know that for a limited time only when
you pick up the performance package 4.0
you also get two free gifts the shed
travel bag and the manscaped
anti-chafing boxers these cooling boxer
briefs might actually be one of the
coolest parts of this collection what's
the point in manscaping your bits like a
pro if you're just gonna throw on some
rags afterwards not only are manscapes
boxers extra comfy but they have fancy
crop cooling technology to keep you cool
and dry
all day long the fabric's super soft and
comes in a wide range of sizes all the
way up to triple xl and what's neat is
that you get to opt into their peak
hygiene plan which means you'll get a
new pair every cycle straight to your
door if all that sounds good then head
over to manscape.com and use promo code
not mark 20 for 20
off free international shipping and two
free gifts underwear
to your door your paws will thank you
bye
sakura this is a section of this arc i
had absolutely no idea was as
controversial as it happens to be before
getting into this i want to be perfectly
clear here i am not part of any naruto
communities online i do not speak about
naruto with anyone and i was not
influenced by anything other than the
material i read to come to these
conclusions and feelings i have
regarding this series i have a number of
things to say about this not all
negative however one thing i have
noticed since reading and writing this
section has been that online some folks
are exceptionally passionate about this
particular argument which is why i have
tried to make my thoughts concerning
this narrative decision as thorough as i
possibly could even double checking my
perspective by asking all of you guys on
twitter so whether we end up agreeing or
disagreeing on this particular occasion
i thank you for your feedback and
thoughts with that said let's get into
my immediate reaction and then my more
nuanced understanding of what kishimoto
was going for and whether or not i
thought he was successful my immediate
reaction to this was a little hyperbolic
everyone i give you the panel of no
return for on this page resting lovingly
upon the top panel kishimoto speed round
the character killing or character
defining moment for sakura depending on
who you're talking to and unfortunately
i find myself leaning much more
negatively for a host of different
reasons i will spend the next while
explaining however i do have some
positives to speak of with regards to
the scene and i want to be clear that i
still stand by all my prior praisings of
her character from earlier in this story
i can't hold young sakura accountable
for the sins of her present self but i
digress
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] this shocked me and
the more i read the more i found myself
leaning back in my chair hand placed
firmly over my face there's a moment
earlier in this act where i confront
sakura about the promise she asked
naruto to keep and the pressure that
promise might put on him on paper this
idea for conflict within the character
of sakura makes sense for both her
character and the story as it could lead
to some interesting conflict however
unfortunately it never fully makes use
of it at best and totally botches its
potential at worst from the outset i
want to make it clear that i am not
someone that believes sakura was being
fickle and just wanted naruto when
sasuke became a non-starter she's not
that shallow i think anyone that thinks
that clearly hasn't read or watched the
material and if they have then they
clearly weren't paying attention if
that's their takeaway i have absolutely
no idea what's going on what i
personally dislike about this scene
isn't just one thing in isolation it's
that it's one hasty naive albeit
well-intentioned for the most part
choice made that has a rolling knock-on
series of obviously negative outcomes
outcomes that should have been
abundantly obvious to anyone
particularly as shinobi like sakura my
first issue
sakura feels guilty for potentially
being a reason naruto is assuming so
much responsibility and pressure
constantly putting himself in danger
potentially risking his own life to
bring sasuke back because it was a
promise that he made to her this is
interesting and absolutely worth
exploring further it's true to her
character however in order to alleviate
that guilt and indeed because she cares
about naruto she decides to lie to him
in an effort to protect him this is
regardless of her reasoning manipulation
and is [ __ ] because in doing so she is
lying to the face of someone she
supposedly cares about using something
that he has deeply wanted in the past a
potential relationship with her and she
knows that my second issue on top of
dangling that fake carrot in front of
him this lie is also attempting to rob
naruto of his autonomy as a character to
force him into making a specific choice
that she agrees with that she thinks is
the right thing to do she's trying to
make the decision for naruto in this
effort of manipulation this to me is
worse than her trying in earnest to get
with naruto because she's done with
sasuke it has layers of manipulation
beneath the surface that while coming
from a good place results in a massively
obvious immature and somewhat selfish
decision being made out of desperation
my third issue the motivation behind the
scene is fine
kinda but the execution could not have
been worse furthermore what sakura tries
to do assuming her goal is to take the
pressure off of naruto and take agency
by going to confront the akatsuki
herself is one of the most
incomprehensibly
dumb decisions anyone could make in this
series at this particular point in time
there's no amount of mental gymnastics i
can perform to rationalize this choice
particularly for someone that's known
for how clever she is now one might say
and rightfully so that people in
desperate times make irrational
decisions this is true however i have
two arguments against this one is
narratively driven and the other is
character driven we'll do the character
one first sakura is a ninja a shinobi a
warrior that has seen some awful things
that has come close to death numerous
times before her speciality requires her
to have a level head in intense
situations and the level with which she
fails to make even the faintest rational
decision here feels incredibly
convenient for the plot and inconvenient
for us sitting at home but i'll get to
that she's been trained as what's
essentially a military operative and if
she's been made aware of just how
powerful sasuke has gotten even remotely
she has to be aware that naruto is the
only one capable of stopping him at that
moment the pain incident proved that
naruto is the strongest ninja in their
village and by an incredibly wide margin
at that taking him off of this
proverbial chessboard would be the
equivalent of not using your queen
because you're too scared of it being
taken out all the while you charging
guns blazing with your good intentions
and a bunch of pawns to your inevitable
demise so yeah sakura makes some
incomprehensibly bad decisions in this
arc which brings me to my narrative
point
no one likes tension built upon a lack
of communication bad communication at
that if your scenes are driven simply by
two characters not being honest with one
another that can very very easily feel
incredibly frustrating for an audience
member if done incorrectly and this just
wasn't the time or place for this for
the longest time sakura has slowly been
slipping into the background of this
series with even characters like
konohamaru getting to do more than her
in recent memory and so for her
character to do something like this
feels annoying at best and idiotic and
dangerous at worst and considering she's
leading a charge with others in her
stead i'm leaning towards the latter
miscommunication now drives this
narrative and while hitachi did do
something similar with sasuke not being
honest with him which created the
tension and conflict in the story around
that time kishimoto approached that
narrative choice completely differently
we never knew any of this was fabricated
on one side and thus the tension felt
natural during the conflict all the
while when it was revealed it did so
during the climax of that narrative
decision with all of the thematic
relevance laid bare alongside the climax
for the world to see in other words we
were able to enjoy it however with this
situation i feel like i already know
where it's going what will happen and
what the lesson will eventually be
sucking all of the fun and drama out of
this supposedly dramatic situation and
finally my fourth issue all of this was
ignited by the advice of psy a character
that is literally defined in the series
by how emotionally unintelligent he is a
person who was in no way equipped to
contribute a meaningful nuance take to
sakura and when he did so she took it
completely to heart hook line and sinker
naturally this is my smallest gripe
admittedly and you could even call it a
nitpick but that's why i left it here
for last and that's just the initial two
chapters as this story with naruto
continues and he eventually catches wind
of what's going on with sakura moving to
attack sasuke this king suffers a panic
attack like my heart sinks for this
character he's trying so hard to do the
right thing to be honest and everyone
around him just seems to be a [ __ ]
suicidal maniac and what's more is this
part didn't even really make sense to me
when i read it the first time
in this psy says to naruto quote that's
why she came here to tell you all of
that now when he says that he means her
and her desire to go off and fight
sasuke to kill him which by the way she
never said all she did was pretend to
profess her love for him and then peace
out without further explanation to which
naruto reasonably responds with why
didn't she just say that and to that
they say it's not that easy and that she
was trying to avoid hurting naruto at no
point did she say what she was doing or
why without psy and everyone else there
to effectively communicate her feelings
for him he would have had literally no
comprehension of what she or her friends
are doing right now despite her
supposedly having come to tell him just
that sakura is someone that made this
choice in an effort to bring naruto into
the least amount of danger she wants him
to succeed and to do well she is his
friend to me this just does not justify
what she did in trying to manipulate him
and only really makes sense if i assume
she is capable of making literally the
worst possible decisions placing herself
and her loved ones in life-threatening
danger all the while achieving the
opposite of what she set out to do
placing naruto into an even more
dangerous and compromising position
because she herself is now in danger
okay time for some positives i think the
reason this frustrated me more than
anything else thus far was primarily
because it could have been really great
first of all let me say that i think
this scene does a lot of cool things
thematically for both characters
involved conversations like these where
two pivotal characters speak frankly
with one another about something
personal or important are usually
terrific and rich with profound
introspection and catharsis sakura and
naruto have a long shared and turbulent
history together ripe for the picking
and in this scene there's plenty of
nuance present that i liked and i
touched on it earlier from sakura's
point of view she sees naruto as someone
that's trapped in his own fantasy a
person she deeply cares about has a love
for her which forces him to take
increasingly more extreme action putting
himself into life-threatening danger she
thinks that's her perspective and
believing that's the reality sakura
feels a tremendous amount of guilt and
responsibility to alleviate that stress
and that's a really cool idea and what
makes it even better is naruto's
response to that
[Music]
this is one of the best decisions made
not only in this arc but perhaps some of
the most important thematic and
character defining lines heading into
this big climax with moderate
highlighting for us as an audience how
naruto handles and doesn't handle every
piece of news that comes his way earlier
in this arc madura expresses to the
world leaders what his ultimate goals
were to seize control over everyone's
autonomy using infinite tsukuyomi the
infinite tsukuyomi is an extremely
powerful genjutsu that traps the entire
world in what is effectively an illusion
enslaving the human population in a
dream so that their chakra may be drawn
upon by the god tree or at least that's
what it says on narutopedia it is in
effect a technique which traps the
victim in a fantasy a delusion and in
the scenes where naruto is forced to
contend with the fantasy and delusion
sakura offers him that he has always
wanted he unflinchingly chooses reality
the more difficult option to not live in
a lie because as he says he hates those
people the responsibility to trudge
forward no matter how hard reality can
be and as we can see it can be extremely
difficult particularly for him and
that's what this arc is all about in a
sense with regards cell 7 or team 7.
each character is at their most
desperate made evident by the crazy
decision sakura made the length sasuke
is willing to go to and obviously with
the way naruto's circumstances are
causing him to feel gone are the days of
childhood concerns and vapid spats we
are on the cusp of war and we feel that
with each subsequent page turn and so
putting a pin on this sakura scene there
are clearly some interesting ideas and
profoundly interesting thematic choices
made that speak wonderfully to the
character of naruto and in some ways
sakura however all of this good i think
really came at the cost of any and all
respect i had for the sakura character
as a competent and level-headed ninja
now time for something completely
different kisame versus killer b is
pretty damn cool i honestly had no idea
kasami could transform like that i mean
was it hinted at before or was it a
surprise for people let me know down
below i'm actually not sure about that
in addition to that i think what i like
most about this fight is what it meant
for this series moving forward this
second form and indeed even the tail
forms killer b utilizes are nothing new
to the series however what's interesting
here is that killer bee seems to be in
complete control of this form and with
that it makes me wonder if naruto will
have to learn how to do the same it
seems like the natural final training
arc for him to undergo on his way to big
final battle i mean it's literally him
mastering the demon inside of him it's a
cool concept but who knows maybe this
speculation is a complete waste of time
the fight itself is really cool with
kisame breaking out a sword that can
suck chakra which comes in handy later
in the fight but moreover as it looks
like he's about to win against killer
bee reikage shows up and then the two
brothers just decapitate kisame which i
wasn't expecting although now that we're
heading towards the end game it makes
sense to nick some characters here and
there
and speaking of nixing some characters
it's time for a fight i wasn't
anticipating to be nearly this damn good
danzo vs sasuke
sasuke's fight with danzo is the battle
i never knew i needed until i got it my
god almighty this fight works on so many
different levels and not just from the
clearly exquisite visuals we see before
us but thematically danzo is a
fascinating individual for sasuke to
square off against from his village both
of these characters represent two
diametrically opposed extreme
convictions neither of which desirable
one willing to do literally everything
in his power to protect his village and
the other desiring nothing more than to
destroy that village neither are seen as
just or virtuous characters within the
story and in effect are both antagonists
i'm probably the only one who made this
association but whenever i see a
character like danzo one that's driven
by extreme measures out of mistrust and
fear of the consequences i think of the
1999 film the iron giant if you haven't
seen this please do it's a brilliant
story and the book it's based off of is
fantastic also set during the cold war
of the 1950s one of the best characters
is kent mansley while there are some
obvious and major differences between
himself and danzo what i find
fascinating about these types of
characters is how easy it is to
empathize with their respective points
of view not to justify their actions
mind you but understand them it ends up
making for some of the most interesting
interactions and colors the world with a
lot more nuance and when danzo removed
that brace from his arm revealing a
litany of sharingan eyes he'd harvested
from the fallen uchia clan i knew this
fight was going to be all sorts of
messed up and it didn't disappoint armed
with an arm of sharingans this battle
between these two fighters erupts into
an incredibly well animated game of
chess hinging the abilities of each
wielder's specific strengths to be
utilized in tandem with either
misdirection or pure tenacity there's a
terrific visual marker established
pathways through the fight with danzo
and his remaining eyes acting as sort of
a lives system sacrificing an eye to
prolong his struggle against sasuke and
that's not to say danzo doesn't do work
in this either he does incredibly well
way better than i thought he would in
terms of choreography and set up for the
fight this one has a very good ending i
think all the while utilizing
misdirection not just on danzo but with
us as an audience too sasuke had cast an
illusion which caused danza to believe
he had a spare sharingan or life so to
speak when in fact he didn't leading to
his desperate gambit at the end
um
[Music]
this
took me by surprise in a good way i knew
what the odds of this happening were but
i really didn't want it to happen karen
had literally been offering up her
lifeblood to sassy in order to
rejuvenate him this whole thought
process was cut off though as danzo goes
full kamikaze mode there's a short but
wonderfully insightful flashback sharing
with us the past of both hirozen and
danzo prior to either of them achieving
higher status in their village each one
acting as a sort of counterbalance so to
speak to the other hirozen would go on
to operate in the light as hokage and
danzo in the shadows both acting in the
interest of the respective village to
the bitter end and quite unlike kent
mansley and iron giant danzo at the very
least is brave enough to die for his
convictions and not become overwhelmed
by the task or foe in front of him it's
a really cool moment that sort of
recontextualizes a lot of what he's done
up until now sort of
sakura and sasuke there's a really cool
scene that takes place immediately
following the aftermath of this
encounter karen is on the verge of death
on the floor waiting to be polished off
by the uncaring sasuke and suddenly
sakura shows up i'm not exactly sure how
i should feel about what she did to her
friends though on the way to meet with
sasuke i mean i'm happy she did what she
could to spare their lives from what
ultimately amounted to a terrible
strategic move i didn't mention it
before but the idea that all of them
would take action like that with little
to no strategy genuinely surprised me
regarding sakura however a large part of
the story deals with sakura actively
making her presence felt in the story
and celebrating her autonomy as a
character but she does so by robbing
everyone else of theirs it's a really
strange decision narratively
particularly because of what happens at
the end of all of this her plans fail
twice achieving nothing and even admits
to some extent that she's just been in
the way so what's being achieved here
exactly
to me it just feels like kishimoto
wanted only cell 7 to be present for the
final confrontation of the ark to
reunite and
didn't have a way of getting sakura
there without her making a host of
extremely rash decisions putting herself
into harm's way and two separate
accounts the first time when her plan if
you can even call it that leading to her
trying to convince sasuke that she's
going to be on his side but he sees
through that
surprises her she fails and then kakashi
has to save her with that said when she
is in the room there's some really nice
imagery evocative of the last moment she
and sasuke had one-on-one before he
initially left he flashes behind her to
thank her in that moment she feels a
connection with sasuke it's kind of nice
however this time he deceives her and
once behind her she felt nothing but an
entirely different person a coldness as
karen put it there's a really cool
thematic visual contrast that speaks to
the progression of these two characters
and their relationship i can see why
kishimoto wanted her to be there in that
moment i just think the means with which
he gets her there is really strange and
almost unbelievable naruto's journey to
this place however has been great trying
to deal with all of the responsibility
all of this stress a panic attack him
escaping in a creative way to deal with
sasuke himself using the sage mode he
learned earlier in the prior arc to
locate him and when he arrives he does
so in dramatic fashion following the
fight with kakashi when he saves sakura
the fight between sask and kashi isn't
super long and apart from the obviously
cool rogue student versus regretful
master dynamic at play one particular
parts it out to me as really nice
sasuke's dialogue or interactions with
kakashi in these moments has him saying
things like only the uchiha are able to
wield the sharing again however through
his adept fighting with it sasuke
acknowledges him well sort of this
happens only in the anime and i i can
see why it wasn't involved in the manga
this fight is actually quite short and
barely a fight at all really and while i
prefer that it isn't drawn out like in
the anime the anime does have a cool
line where sasuke declares that he's
about to show what a real master of the
sharing gang can do only for him to
start losing his sight it's a really
nice visual touch that draws attention
to the path he's heading down with his
spirit kaiju fading away just like his
vision and in that moment sakura takes
advantage of the situation yet again
now uh
i bet a lot of people hate on this but
at the same time this is a uniquely
difficult situation to be in and one she
thought or at least wanted to believe
she was capable of following through
with and honestly i think i understand
both sides of this argument not to say
i'm sitting on the fence here i think
while the idea was interesting the
execution left a lot to be desired i
will however say that what happens in
this scene surrounding these characters
reminds me a lot of what happened to two
particular characters in attack on titan
what i'm about to say has some big
spoilers for the first half of season 4
which aired last year so skip to this
timestamp if you want to avoid those
spoilers
[Music]
this reminded me a lot of the
conversations and hatred a lot of people
directed and had for the character of
gabby gang gabby gang gabby gang gang
gabby after she killed sasha despite
many of those same people not feeling
nearly as much negativity towards
aaron's actions which led to the deaths
of thousands that same night all because
we're following aaron's story and not
gabby's similar to that in this story
we've been following the life of naruto
and have built a strong connection with
him many of us on a personal level as
made evident by my twitter mentions
because of this sakura a character which
has played an increasingly smaller role
as of late in the series suddenly starts
taking not only an active role driving
her own tale but makes choices that
actively make the life of the main
character that we're following so much
harder for reasons that honestly don't
make a lot of sense outside of her
feeling that she has to be part of or
shoulder some of this responsibility
ultimately achieving nothing i genuinely
think that partially due to her
inactivity it created a situation where
fans were far less likely to be
charitable towards her actions but
that's just my take and that brings us
to the end of the five kage summit i had
intended uncovering more in this video
but when i discovered how heated the
conversation and dialogue online was
surrounding sakura in this particular
act i knew that i had to dive in there
with a lot more detail plus this act had
a surprising amount happen too like
danzo becoming the temporary sixth
lukake the five kage summon itself the
fourth shinobi war being declared could
it be versus kisame sasuke versus danzo
and of course team sevens reuniting
speaking of which
uh
if you do disagree with anything i said
that's cool everyone's entitled to their
own takes on a fictional character and
while i know this might be a futile
effort much like sakura i'm gonna try
anyway please be kind to each other in
the comment section i know without even
looking it's going to be a hellscape but
please just try to respect everyone you
know we're all human beings at the end
of the day next week i'll be starting
the fourth shinobi war arcs and i hope i
can see you there until then i've been
told not sakura and i'll see you all
next time
[Music]